hier guck mal ich glaube hier dann
vorbei es war noch dann ist es auch
wieder falsch obwohl ich hallo freunde
wir spielen heute ein spiel was quasi
einfach meine herausforderung des lebens
darstellt und zwar nach einem
genussvollen abend irgendwie nach hause
kommen das ist das womit ich mich mein
leben lang hier beschäftige ihr seht
schon hier eingeblendet go home you're
drunk ich hab's gesehen er captain
sparkurs habe mir gedacht das spiel ist
allerdings waren wir jetzt heute noch
unterwegs mit stürmer film mit verloren
und mit pedale und blabla und wir haben
paar sachen gemacht und dann habe ich
mich nachher noch mit smart ein paar
spieler unterhalten und dann hatte er ja
auch selbst spielt habe ich auch vor
zwei tagen gebracht also ich möchte es
nicht dass das gegen die wehr war ein
zuhälter ist es kopiert dann fängt man
rum und alles was sagst du dazu ist
geklaut aber ist okay
denn gedacht warum nicht locker dann
könnten sie einfach mal spielen und das
machen wir jetzt auch ein paar mal
kommentierte play ok 10 highscore 0 med
video vorbei das war sie also ich kann
meine wsd tasten benutzen um hier
irgendwie zu laufen und ich kann so
kommt jetzt ich kann auch irgendwie
springen wenn ich die leertaste nehmen
und dann womöglich sind gelaufen ist er
denn behindert wenn der hier nicht die
wie soll ich denn um die mülltonne rom
kommen sogar dicker jetzt und jetzt nach
rechts
das ist doch nicht war kann ich nicht
irgendwie hat der typ eigentlich
überhaupt arme das sieht so aus als
hätte ich schon direkt weiter hier jetzt
kommt kommen jetzt springen doch man bas
dr keys to move don't really space
shuttles ausser works with joy stick
nicht bewegte sich der nicht geht
es geht auch um jetzt hier nochmal das
kann doch nicht sein ich muss doch
irgendwie
ganz langsam gehen reduziert auch mal
deine geschwindigkeit man wenn ich doch
nach hinten drückt jetzt das wird ok
freunde ganz ruhig bleiben ich habe es
im gefühl dass das ich jetzt meinen run
wird es kann nicht schwer sei nicht
ja ja ja ja ja aber jetzt lammert muss
irgendwie schon vorher so caspar dohmen
wasserflasche vom jetzt da ist so viel
platz
danke schön das schaffe ich doch niemals
jetzt komm ich mache einfach immer ich
arbeite richtig viel zu springen
distance wiese steht der highscore zwei
bis drei dass das hier kommt jetzt mein
leben ich habe nichts berührt dann
nimmst dir mal mülltonne mit meinen kurz
freunde wie soll das funktionieren
komme ich versucht jetzt mal so ein
bisschen es ist nicht wahr das geht
nicht schon mal ich hoffe dir dann
vorbei ich glaub ich hab eine taktik ich
muss zwar vorstand zu drücken habe dann
aber ich glaube ich habe ich habe doch
gar nichts berührt die bindung oder
durchgelaufen
- 40 mal mehr als minus treviso bewegen
sich denn diese teile überhaupt was ist
so schwer daran dass ich es nicht
hinkriegen da einfach mal an diesen
teilen vorbei zu laufen
ich habe doch nichts berührt ich bin ich
will eine wiederholung
wisst ihr nicht scheiße etwas bin und da
wenn ich scheiße in etwas bin dann sehe
ich das ja auch ein dann habe ich daher
weiß ich ja okay kann ich nicht aber
hier hab ich doch wieder nichts berührt
die guck mal ich laufe hier dann vorbei
es war doch ich hüpfe jetzt einfach die
ganze zeit
es ist es ist nicht wahr
wenn es so wäre dass ich da nicht
durchkommen würde ja ok jetzt ist klar
da springe ich natürlich auch die
mülltonne stark gemacht aber jetzt hier
schaut mal ich laufe hier dran
ja da bin ich jetzt natürlich auch
dagegen dann gelaufen aber jetzt da war
ich jetzt auch oder mülltonnen aber wenn
ich jetzt beispielsweise mal hier dann
so rumlaufen
dann ist es auch wieder falsch obwohl
ich
11freunde der kamera tatsächlich nur
untermieterin an und meinte ich würde
hier so rumpold eventuell abgesehen dass
ich da meinen stuhl ein bisschen um
geklickt haben ich weiß nicht wie die
das hören konnte ich habe schon viel
schlimmere sachen eigentlich so also
viel lauter war ich ein geschaut aber
jetzt gerade
ein krankenwagen rum und ich ja das
akzeptiere ich okay da will ich gegen
gelaufen
hier ist natürlich kacke da laufe ich
natürlich direkt das ding um hier stehen
die natürlich dann auch wieder kacke ich
muss glaube ich einfach mal so ein
bisschen langsam loslaufen joão dass das
ist der plan
langsam los laufen nicht so ganz langsam
lauf konzentrier dich auf deinen fuß
ging hier um sein dass er hat nicht
berührt freunde jetzt hier das ist jetzt
das beste um zu zeigen ich laufe durch
ich habe nichts berührt habe nichts
berührt ich springe motto was mein
highscores 7 dicker ich bin einfach
gesprungen wie so ein boss ich glaube
das ist die taktik oder
das ist auf jeden fall die taktik locker
das war nicht gut wie habe ich das
lenkrad gemacht dass ich so doof in der
luft war ich nach hinten nach vorne
sichtbar
ich muss doch einfach jetzt die
wahrscheinlich wieder von brammo sprung
raus lassen sagte cic drei und alle die
jetzt eventuell mein hirn gesteuert doch
vielleicht sogar ein bisschen komisch
schaut hier auf meine auf meine finger
und kamera kamera damit faktisch schätze
und ich verstehe es halt einfach nicht
wie kann denn ein spiel also natürlich
dafür dass in 19 minuten in 15 stunden
wirst wie was aber dafür dass es in 15
stunden entwickelt wurde ist es keine
frage ist es sehr gut aber wenn ich nach
vorne drücken dann läufst du gefälligst
auch nach vorne ich möchte noch einmal
diesen babo sprung da hinkriegen dass
ich einfach da noch einmal so durch die
komplette
soll einfach nicht sein noch einen
allerletzten leben ich versuche den
hardcore sprung hinzukriegen kommen
jetzt hier und wenn es euch gefallen hat
würde ich mich wie immer über eine
bewertung freuen das ist doch nicht wahr
dass etwa die mülltonne reinbringen auch
schon mal distance vier das war ganz
schön
ich würde mich über eine bewertung
freund schreibt mir die kommentare
eventuell andere spiele die ihr kennen
die so behindert sind oder den besondern
spiele ich die und stadt das event
zusammen